hello and welcome to the introductory
lesson the AWS Solutions Architect
associate level course offered by simply
learned in this lesson you will get a
brief overview about the course and how
the certification can help your career
simply learns AWS certified solution
architect associate level course will
help you understand the key concepts
required to prepare for the
certification exam the practice
assignments and the three live projects
are included especially for you to gain
hands-on experience with the AWS
management console so you can become a
domain expert in designing the best
possible infrastructure solution this
course comprises of twenty-four hours of
instructor led training 15 hours of
eLearning
over 50 demonstrations to understand
architecting through the AWS console and
you will also be provided with three
question sets totaling 108 of questions
Amazon Web Services provides a highly
reliable scalable low-cost
infrastructure platform in the cloud
that powers hundreds of thousands of
businesses in 190 countries around the
world
the worldwide cloud computing market
grew 28% to 110 billion dollars in
revenues in 2015 in the last quarter of
2015
AWS revenue was up 69 percent
year-on-year
the certification holder takes home an
average salary of around 126 thousand
dollars which is up from 115 thousand
dollars last year according to Forbes in
2015 there are over 18 million jobs in
the field of cloud computing globally
AWS Solutions Architect
associate level is the perfect
certification to start your journey with
AWS you'll enhance your existing
knowledge of AWS and will deepen your
understanding of every product and
service that AWS offers so you can fully
grasp how cloud computing redefines the
rules of architecting IT infrastructure
you will learn how to design plan and
scale in the AWS cloud using Amazon
recommended best practices to ensure you
make the most of cloud computing with
the certification will be an asset to
any organization helping it to leverage
the benefits of best practices around
advanced cloud-based solutions and
migrate existing workloads to the cloud
whether you're looking to future-proof
your career or just prove you'll know
how about the leading cloud provider in
the global market becoming an AWS
solutions architect associate will put
you well on your way to achieving your
career goals let's take a look at some
of the prerequisites for this course you
should ideally be an IT professional
with experience in both traditional IT
infrastructure and the AWS platform you
should be aware of topics such as high
availability and business continuity
costing deployment management network
design data storage security scalability
and elasticity cloud migration and
hybrid architecture it's highly
recommended that you complete the AWS
technical essentials course before
taking up the AWS Solutions Architect
course
you can reach out to our teaching
assistant support staff anytime during
the course and for assistance with
projects candidates can submit their
queries at help and support on our
website or they can get connected with
our staff using simply talk and the live
chat options this concludes the course
introduction and we hope you're all
geared up to begin the AWS Solutions
Architect associate level course let's
get started for the first lesson
AWS overview happy learning